foreign
so I recorded this episode and as soon
as it was over I was just sick to my
stomach for a couple of reasons
um I wasn't in a great headspace going
into the show and instead of being a
grown-up and having a hard conversation
with Kelly and the team saying hey
today's not a great day I got stuff
going on my personal life just a lot
going on
um I went ahead and did it and I ended
up I think uh blowing a couple of calls
and normally I would edit this out and I
would take it out um and y'all would
never know what happened and it would
just be a private little moment between
me and the caller and it would never see
the light of air or sweet Sarah would
edit around it all and try to make me
look good
and the reason I think it's important to
put these calls out in this way is
number one they happen in the same show
I was having a bad day
and number two I think it's important
for me to be able to say hey here's
where I messed up and I want you to take
this lesson into your lives into your
marriages into your friendships into
your dating relationships into your
relationship with with your kids
um because
sometimes expertise is having the right
answer in the right moment and sometimes
expertise and wisdom is about saying hey
now's not a great time let me Circle
back let me go for a walk around the
block give me 30 minutes I need 24 hours
to think about this and let's Circle
back so in this first call
a woman called
um about her husband and his weight gain
and the way she describes his weight
gain and
um
you can you can hear the call but it set
me off in a way that I ended up
allowing myself
I I I'm not gonna say I got dragged into
it I entered into her
um toxic relationship I joined in and I
became a part of a really messed up
Dynamic that as a as the person she was
seeking counsel from wisdom from I
should have stayed Above The Fray I
should have stayed outside of it and I
didn't I got involved and by getting
involved I neglected a really important
piece of wisdom for her and her husband
which is he needs to go see a medical
doctor asap
because he's had some dramatic life
changes and I did focus a lot on
potential depression focused a lot on
her behavior and actions and the way
she's treating him and talking to him
but because I got carried away and I got
frustrated in the middle of that call I
allowed myself to get in the middle of
this thing
um where I didn't belong
I I missed I missed Healthcare 101 which
is man if you've got some significant
weight gain some significant life
changes and you're not well
go see your doctor asap start there
start with a blood test start with a
relationship with your primary care
physician or a specialized doctor start
there and I got carried away and so I
blew it and so I just want to say that
up front as you listen to this call know
that the first thing I should have told
her was
hey you gotta love this guy B
he needs to go see a doctor today all
right so here's my call with Jane from
Houston Jane from Houston here we go
what's up Jane
hello Dr Delaney how are you
um
I'm good but I can already hear it hi Dr
Maloney how are you what happened
well um I'm concerned about the state of
my marriage
through the course of our marriage my
husband has gained a significant amount
of what at least 70 pounds
and it greatly affects our activities we
can do together
be it from just taking a walk going for
a hike
in our sexual activities
and
I'm just feeling like I want more and he
refuses to do anything to improve his
health
and so
my quandary here is on one hand I feel
resentful about it that there's a lot of
stuff we can't do together eat like I
say even just go on for a walk
and then on the other hand I say okay
fine I'll just go do my own thing
explore my own hobbies and oh you want
to get back
I don't want to build up resentment and
oh you're way past life I know you're
way past that I know a woman being
resentful come on okay listen
um
genocent usually I get like one or two
lines Jenna sent
a big chunk of your original email
can we go to the can we go to the bottom
of it
okay I don't have it printed out not the
bottom of it like get to the bottom of
it
what you just presented
was this
um
concerned wife who's just worried about
the health of my husband and I think
that I think that I think that's true
but here's what you wrote okay I'm gonna
read it back to you okay
my husband has gained over 60 pounds
since we married 12 years he drinks at
least a six pack of beer throughout the
day in a night cap or two he eats out
all the time and eats so much junk food
his weight gain has affected our sex
life in his prior marriage his wife did
one thing to do with him
and refused to have sex with him
therefore since he had nothing else to
do he was the workout King he was so hot
why did she get hot Mike and I only get
Fat Mike I enjoyed our sex life early in
our marriage and I don't know what to do
he has bigger boobs than me or his boobs
are bigger than mine okay so that's a
different level of disdain there tell me
about that
no it's a turn off I know I'm not
talking about
I'm talking about like the
one of those is like I'm a concerned
wife I'm worried about his health we
can't do things together and I'm I'm
starting to feel alone
one of them the other story is
his first wife got the good mic and I
got the leftover bum mic and what kind
of bum am I married to that's a totally
different track here talk me through
that no well because I have any other
aspect he's great and wonderful but
why previously did he in his previous
marriage did he put in the effort to
take care of himself and be healthy and
now he claims he's happier than he's
ever been and yet he just keeps getting
bigger
so I mean you hear it as you ask it
right
right tell me about his ex-wife
we've already made this conversation
weird we're gonna get super weird all
right her
apparently she had mental health issues
okay you know I'm only hearing his side
of course and there is every excuse for
not being an intimate afraid of having
kids didn't want to mess up the kids and
you know
every excuse for not being intimate and
so he said well I had nothing else to do
so I just worked out okay just between
you and me that's nonsense okay
um
what
moves sex over to the side tell me about
her what did she demand of him
he put her through graduate school okay
as far as what she demanded of their
relationship I know nothing beyond that
that was long before we met okay what do
you demand of him
I want to spend time together and doing
stuff
how do you get there
currently all we can do together is
and we're drinking
but this is not a big drinker this
didn't happen overnight though true so
true early in our marriage
it was we were working you know raising
a child and we're both working 60 80
hours a week and
you know our sex life was great
oftentimes you know you hit the bed and
you're exhausted both of us equally
exhausted and reach over you know hey
babe I love you I really want you I'm
just you know the body's weak we're
exhausted
you know
and but now we've raised our child he's
moved on with life and
my husband had this picture the the
child leaves a nest and overright we're
gonna be having rocking sex all the time
but he's gained all this weight
and it is sex's ability to perform and
so now his solution is I should
do other things that
I'm not particularly interested in you
know let's go to a strip club I want to
see a stripper give you a lap dance you
know as a woman that's not a turn-on for
me yeah and you
so
and ew
um
that actually that actually more
confirms what I thought
um
he's quit
he's completely given up
he doesn't like who he's become in this
new life
and since he's not on the phone I can
only talk to you okay and what I hear
is a woman who does not like her husband
dude I love a lot of people that I can't
stand
but you don't like him
I want to be able to do stuff
you're trying to I 100 agree with you
but you're trying to protect yourself
and I need you to stop for a second
you don't like him and I don't think
you've liked him for a long time
and there is oh man there is no greater
way to to
deflate a man than to look at him and
say I'm disappointed in you
and if you've been disappointed with him
over this my guess is over time you've
been disappointed in him a lot now I'm
not blaming you for where he's where he
ended up this has been his choice his
decision
and now he's grasping at straws because
he doesn't like who he has become
and so he is looking for ways to
increase his heart rate
that's why he's gonna keep coming up
with more wild and more wild and more
wild because he has to deflect this
issue and make it not his make it yours
the same way you've deflected this issue
for years and made it all his
and if I'm wrong tell me I'm wrong I'm
willing to be wrong
no I can
I can see that
my guess is in
how to be careful how I say that
um
I don't know that he sees any value in
what comes next
other than to keep you from hassle on
him
and whose son was it was it your son
bringing to the marriage or was it his
mine yours do you love that boy
yes absolutely
um
I'm wondering if putting his first wife
through grad school and feeling like he
had a role to play there
even though that role killed him because
it wasn't reciprocated
and having a young man to raise stepping
into that boy's life and seeing him off
to his next adventure
and it sounds like a guy without a
purpose
other than just to stop being hassled
well I help him find that purpose
you gotta first tell them that you like
him that you're on his team
not just he's not performing for you and
he's because he's gotten too fat
and that you got ripped off in this deal
your whole language is you got you got
you got ripped off
instead of seeing I've got a hurting man
in front of me who's dying here and my
trying to beat him up all these years
all the over all these things
that's that's not working
yeah and I don't feel I've been beating
them up because I only approached it a
few times of hey let's go for a walk
let's do something together I would be
willing to bet money I don't have a lot
but I'd be willing to bet money that
if I was talking to him
he's had a hard time making you happy
over the years is that fair or no
I don't think so
just out of the blue he just suddenly
went from super hot
um always in the gym always working out
to suddenly
having to drink himself
to a a coma every night
no you know
when we got together neither of us was
working out because we didn't have time
we were both working a couple of jobs
and you know now our child is raised
you know we're both self-employed we're
debt free
let's find something that we can do
together let's
you know enjoy life do something go see
the country or something but do you see
anything
you don't like your life either
I I hope you can see the dance that's
happening here
is you got a guy who doesn't like who
he's become
and so he blames himself
and he's going to slowly eat and drink
himself to death
and he's got a wife who doesn't like who
she's become
but heaven forbid she blame herself so
she blames him
for the life that she's getting ripped
off from
and it becomes this weird wobbly dance
that nobody wins
until either he drops dead or you leave
so how do I help him find
who he wants to become
I'm leaving the marriage I love them
you know and I want him to be happy and
I want to fulfill his dreams and
Fantasies
he's he's got to be involved
yeah
will he go to marriage counseling with
you
probably not
why not
he went to counseling previous in his
previous marriage and it went nowhere
okay
so been there done that the working out
been there done that didn't work in the
previous marriage and so
you know why try it again
yeah I don't I don't do diagnosis on
this show but that's a depressed guy
who's done he's just out
you've heard of the diseases of despair
correct it's a lonely guy
and again in no way am I excusing him
I'm just trying to paint you a picture
that the path to his heart the path to
what comes next the path to building
this life you want to have with him
where y'all are just living your best
self now that you got kids out of the
house
the path to him is not through
strip clubs and the path to him is not
through
um hassling him and calling him fat and
making fun of his boobs and
get on to him about his drinking
at the end of the day here's the truth
you can only
control one person on the planet and
that's you
and so what I would recommend for you is
if he won't go with you it's his loss at
this time
but I would go see a counselor myself
and not one to
the whole call the whole approach here
is there's something wrong with him
but you can't fix him what you can fix
is you and so I want not that you need
to be fixed but learn some new dance
moves learn some new ways to navigate
this relationship
and I would tell you to start with I've
got to ReDiscover do I like this guy yes
I'll love him you'll love him for the
End of Time
but I like him
and does he know that I like him
but I don't think that's where you start
I think there's one layer beneath that
and I think you start with
calling a counselor and during the
intake and they say why you want to come
I want you to tell them I don't think I
like who I've become
I've become somebody I don't want to be
and I've
participated in creating an environment
where people aren't healthy
where I'm not healthy my husband's not
healthy but I can't do anything about
him I can only do something about me
and I need to get back in touch with the
the woman that I love
that I like
so that I can reach out and let my
husband know that I like him too
but you sound bitter you sound
frustrated and I'm not saying you
shouldn't be man it sounds like your
whole relationship's just sideways
and you bet you got a husband who's
given up
I just want to give you a little bit of
Hope
sometimes it just takes a little bitty
spark to set the whole place on fire
and maybe by you going to do the work
that you need to do for you
he can be inspired he can see the light
coming on in the house again he can see
that woman look across the room and say
I like you
and I'm willing to work on this thing if
you are
that's my best guess here and if he
wants to call on the show I would love
love love to talk to him Jane I would
love to if he would um if he'd do you
want to call
if he does want to call let Jenna know
and we'll get that set up ASAP
I'm rooting for you man I'll help any
way I can if you've got some specific
questions man but this um
someone's got to turn the lights on and
stop the music and say we're not doing
this dance anymore
I'm getting well I hope you'll join me